il a été décidé ce matin en conseil de
défense que des mesures supplémentaires
seraient prises dans un certain nombre
de territoires dans les prochaines
heures
des concertations seront amenés par
l'état avec les élus locaux dans les
régions île de france et au de france et
dans les départements qui sont continues
à ces régions pour partager l'état de la
situation actuelle pour recueillir
l'avis des élus locaux sur les
différentes mesures qui sont envisagées
le premier ministre réunira par ailleurs
cet après-midi les comités de liaison
parlementaire à l'issue de ce travail
le premier ministre avec le ministre des
solidarités et de la santé annoncera
demain à 18 heures dans une conférence
de presse
les mesures qui seront retenus pour ces
territoires pour une application à
partir de ce week-end